[Música]
19 personas entre ellas 9 menores de
edad perdieron la vida tras un incendio
registrado en el distrito del bronx en
nueva york' es la segunda conflagración
mortal en menos de una semana en ese
país después de que dos personas
fallecieron en circunstancias similares
en filadelfia
el oficialismo admitió su derrota en el
proceso electoral del día de hoy en
venezuela donde se eligió gobernador del
estado de barinas estos comicios fueron
una repetición de los realizados el 21
de noviembre pasado y que entonces
fueron anulados por el tribunal supremo
de justicia afín al oficialismo
nueva jornada de manifestaciones en
varias ciudades de sudan contra el
gobierno militar que surgió del golpe de
estado del 25 de octubre de 2021 al
menos una persona murió con lo que el
número de víctimas desde el inicio de
las protestas aumentó a 62 según
organizaciones civiles
bienvenidos nuevamente a un resumen de
las noticias más importantes de la
jornada
comenzamos en eeuu al menos 19 personas
murieron en nueva york' y decenas más
resultaron heridas cuando un incendio
arrasó un edificio residencial el
domingo por la mañana en el distrito del
bronx entre los muertos hay nueve niños
la primera hipótesis que maneja el
cuerpo de bomberos de la ciudad es una
estufa eléctrica que prendió fuego en
uno de los apartamentos al parecer las
llamas se expandieron rápidamente debido
a que la puerta del recinto quedó
abierta mientras tanto los
sobrevivientes se enfrentan a comenzar
el nuevo año sin hogar
descrito por el alcalde de nueva york
como uno de los peores incendios en la
historia de la ciudad este edificio en
el bronx se vio envuelto en llamas
después de que se produjera un incendio
en la torre de apartamentos el domingo
por la mañana muchos residentes
padecieron por la inhalación de humo
debido a que la puerta del apartamento
donde se originaron las llamas quedó
abierta guanta walking 23 una vez que
estaba subiendo las escaleras de un
cuerpo en el piso que intentaron
rescatar
un perro estaba muerto y fue realmente
devastador nunca en mi vida experimenté
algo tan malo como eso
el edificio de 19 pisos no tiene
escalera de emergencia y los testigos
describieron haber visto a los
residentes pidiendo ayuda desde sus
ventanas al menos 200 bomberos
respondieron al incendio docenas de
personas murieron y muchas más
resultaron heridas a pesar de que los
equipos de bomberos llegaron al lugar
minutos después de la primera llamada de
emergencia de wones
se encontraron en el pasillo con este
fuego humo muy denso fuego muy denso las
unidades empujaron este humo se extendió
por toda la altura del edificio
completamente inusual los miembros se
encontraron víctimas en cada piso y
escaleras y la sacaron con paro cardíaco
y respiratorio en coria que el respeto
euros la causa del incendio aún se
desconoce pero lugar era una vivienda
social y se mantienen dudas sobre que
también se ha hecho el mantenimiento del
edificio especialmente porque este
último incendio se produce pocos días
después de una conflagración en otro
proyectos de viviendas en filadelfia en
donde murieron 12 personas y en
venezuela el oficialismo le concedió el
triunfo a la oposición en las elecciones
a gobernador en el estado de barinas de
tradición chavista los comicios habían
tenido que repetirse por orden del
tribunal supremo cercano al oficialismo
que invalidó los del 21 de noviembre en
los que había ganado por un estrecho
margen el opositor freddy superlano el
ex canciller jorge arreaza quien era el
principal contendor de sergio garrido
hizo el anuncio desde su cuenta de
'twitter' y se lee barinas querida la
información que recibimos de nuestras
estructuras del psv indican que aunque
aumentamos en votación no hemos logrado
el objetivo
agradezco de corazón a nuestra heroica
militancia seguiremos protegiendo al
pueblo barinés desde todos los espacios
y en brasil en las fuertes lluvias que
azotan al estado de minas gerais en el
sureste del país dejan al menos a 138
ciudades en situación de emergencia
la defensa civil calcula al menos 6
personas han perdido la vida como
consecuencia del periodo lluvioso que
inició en octubre pasado unas 17.000
personas también han tenido que ser
evacuadas de sus casas debido a las
intensas precipitaciones que arrecian en
la región
y en medio de este temporal un grave
accidente tuvo lugar el sábado en el
lago de furnas cuando el desprendimiento
de una enorme pared rocosa de un cañón
cayó sobre cuatro barcas dejando un
saldo de diez fallecidos y una treintena
de heridos se cree que el accidente pudo
ser producto de las intensas lluvias que
han azotado a esta región durante las
últimas dos semanas andrés granadillo
nos cuenta más un lamentable rescate se
dio en brasil- este domingo cuando
bomberos y buzos se encontraron varios
cuerpos de turistas inicialmente
reportados como desaparecidos tras el
desprendimiento de una pared rocosa en
minas gerais las autoridades confirmaron
la muerte de 10 personas o más de una
treintena de heridos que fueron
alcanzados por una gigantesca ola que se
formó tras la caída de la columna rocosa
en el agua
el cuerpo de bomberos militares de minas
gerais informa que hoy 9 de enero de
2022 alrededor de las 9 35 horas se
encontró otro cuerpo de la tragedia en
capitolio los turistas se encontraban
recorriendo el agua en lanchas de motor
este sábado por cuatro embarcaciones se
vieron afectadas en el momento del
colapso de la roca y dos embarcaciones
fueron impactadas directamente creando
antes del accidente las embarcaciones se
movían lentamente cerca del acantilado
de roca escarpada en el lago furnas la
mayoría de los heridos fue dado de alta
de los hospitales el sábado por la noche
este sitio es un atractivo turístico
popular en el área aproximadamente a 420
kilómetros al norte de sao paulo la
región ha estado bajo fuertes lluvias
durante dos semanas lo que podría haber
aflojado en la pared rocosa generando
inestabilidad en los suelos erosionados
el sábado un dique se desbordó en una
mina de hierro a 300 kilómetros al este
afectando una importante carretera
federal y en europa este domingo se
sumaron a las protestas contra las
medidas para contener la ola de kobe de
1996 bajos y bélgica
el sábado miles de manifestantes de
varias ciudades de alemania italia y
francia también salieron en las calles
en el país galo el descontento se
agudizó tras las medidas del gobierno
que busca imponer para los no vacunados
el ejecutivo las defiende y advierte que
proseguirá con su plan de implementar un
pase de vacunación en informes de
rodrigo se dan
no cesa la polémica en francia en torno
al paseo vacunal el pasado jueves la
asamblea nacional aprobó la proposición
de ley que sólo permitirá entrar a
espacios públicos a personas con la
pauta completa de vacunación ahora
deberá pasar al senado no exenta de
polémica entretanto este domingo el
portavoz del gobierno gabriela tal ha
defendido su implantación
elegimos el pase de salud y luego el
pase de vacunas y obtuvimos resultados
después del anuncio del pase de salud de
este verano 12 millones de franceses
fueron a vacunarse después del anuncio
del cambio el pase de salud a un pase de
vacunación allí vimos una vez más un
aumento de personas que se vacunaron que
recibieron sus refuerzos en el foro
happel a tal defendió esta medida ante
la obligatoriedad de la vacuna porque
afirma en países como austria no ha sido
efectiva sus declaraciones llegan
después de que miles de personas
salieran el sábado a las calles de parís
en protesta por la medida las marchas
fueron convocadas por el candidato de
extrema derecha florián filippo conocido
por su postura a favor de la salida de
francia de la unión europea
es un ataque a nuestras libertades no
estoy vacunado se lo digo inmediatamente
son nuestras libertades macro no respeta
la constitución por lo que es muy grave
para mí
entre los manifestantes aún resonaban
las palabras de macrón a le parisien el
presidente dijo que tenía ganas de
fastidiar a los no vacunados
es sumamente grave que un presidente
diga eso la población lo odia la
populación
pese a sus declaraciones y una ola de
contagios que rondan los 300.000 casos
diarios en el país macrón sigue siendo
primero en las encuestas cambiamos de
continente a 62 e se elevó el número de
muertos al parecer al manos de las
fuerzas de seguridad de sudán desde el
golpe de estado del pasado 25 de octubre
este domingo falleció un manifestante
tras una nueva jornada de protestas en
la capital jartúm y otras ciudades
aledañas que se oponen al gobierno de
transición miles de ciudadanos rechazan
abdelfatah al burhan quien tomó el poder
después de la sublevación militar
un acuerdo de transición del poder
compartido con los civiles
queremos terminar el golpe militar que
tiene lugar en sudan y apoya la
transición democrática en el país
rechazamos el gobierno militar y la
administración del general arte fatal
burhan
salvo voy a protestar contra el gobierno
militar
queremos un gobierno civil además de
libertad paz seguridad y justicia bajo
un gobierno democrático y naciones
unidas anunció el cese de sus
actividades humanitarias en la convulsa
región etíope de tigre la decisión fue
tomada luego de que hacia la medianoche
del pasado viernes en la localidad de
dvd presenciar a un nuevo ataque aéreo
que impactó en un campamento de
desplazados internos y acabó con la vida
de decenas de personas la guerra de
tigre salió el 4 de noviembre de 2020
cuando el gobierno ordenó una ofensiva
contra el partido político que gobernaba
la región
así llegamos al final quédense con
nosotros
[Música]